one problem fifty-five to five if y is
equal to 4 plus X -3 squared then Y is
lowest when X is equal to so think about
when will this be this expression be the
lowest possible number well if you think
about this whole term right here this X
minus 3 squared any number squared if
we're dealing with real numbers it's
going to be a positive number right so
you could say that X minus 3 squared is
going to be greater than or equal to 0
right 0 is kind of its minimum point so
this whole value is going to be as small
as possible when X minus 3 squared is as
small as possible right because that's
the variable part of it and this is
going to be as small as possible when X
minus 3 is equal to 0 and when is X
minus 3 going to be equal to 0 we could
write it out when is X minus 3 equal to
0
we'll add 3 to both sides it's when X is
equal to 3 so the lowest Y is lowest
when X minus 3 is equal to 0 or X is
equal to 3 and that's choice D and all
you have to recognize is the lowest
value that this function contained is
when this is is not then this term kind
of goes to 0 because otherwise it's a
positive terminal only add to the 4 next
problem 56 which of the following is not
equal to the square of an integer not
equal to the square of an integer so
they say the square root of the square
root of 1 square root of 1 is 1 and the
square root of that is that's going to
be equal to 1 I mean you could have said
negative 1 but then that would have been
undefined so fair enough one of the
roots of the roots is 1 and this is the
square of an integer right this is equal
to 1 squared 2 square root of 4 square
root of 4 that equals 2 now is that is
that the square of an integer no that's
that's equal to square root of 2 squared
but this clearly is not an integer right
so the choice is 2 2 is not equal to the
square of an integer now we could look
at the other ones you know
of 18/2 yeah nine is the square of 341 -
25 that's 1636 so all of the other ones
the squares of integers does a fairly
straightforward problem I think one
problem 5757 Fermat Prime's for prime
numbers that can be written in the form
2 to the K + 1 where K is an integer and
a power of 2 where K is an integer and a
power of 2 so K is integer and power of
2 which of the following is not a Fermat
prime so a 3 well 3 is equal to what
it's equal to 2 to the 1 plus 1 right
and K and in this case k is 1 which is a
power of 2 that's 2 to the 0 B is 5 well
5 is what that equals 2 squared plus 1/4
plus 1 and this is definitely a power of
2 2 is the power of 2 2 to the first C
1717 that's 2 to the fourth plus 1 right
2 to the fourth is 16 plus 1 + 4 is 2
squared so that's a power of 2 choice D
31 let's see that is C the closest power
if we subtract 1 from it if we subtract
1 from it I it's yeah - 2 something does
not equal 30 right that would have to be
true if 2 to the K + 1 is equal to 31
then 2 to the K would have to equal 30
and I can't think of an integer where I
take 2 to some power and I get 30 so the
choice is D D is not a Fermat Prime and
if you wanted to make sure that it's not
e e is 257 well that's just 2 to the
eighth plus 1/2 to the 8th is 256
and that's 257 so the answer is D 58
fifty-eight if x squared x squared is
equal to 2y to the third and 2 y is
equal to four they want to know what x
squared plus y is equal to okay x
squared plus y well they tell us that x
squared is equal to 2y to the third so
let's just substitute that alright so
then we get 2y to the third plus y using
this information in that information and
it tell us 2y is equal to 4 just divide
both sides by two you get Y is equal to
two so let's substitute that into this
so two what's 2 to the third power well
it's 8 plus 2 so I don't want to divide
so that equals 16 plus 2 which is equal
to 18 which is choice E next problem 59
a glucose solution contains 15 grams of
glucose 15 grams of glucose per hundred
cubic centimeters of solution 15 grams
per 100 cubic centimeters centimeters
cubed of solution if 45 cubic
centimeters of solution were poured into
an empty container how many grams of
glucose would be in the container so we
could just set up a ratio we have 15
grams per 100 so how many grams are
going to have per 45 centimeters cubed
how many grams right so they still want
to know grams all the units are the same
and so let's see if we can we can cross
multiply we could say 15 times 45 is
equal to 100 times X so 15 times 45 is
equal to 100 X 100 times X and just to
make the math easy let's divide by some
numbers let's divide both sides by 5
so then this becomes 20 and then this
becomes 9 I'm going to divide both sides
by 5 again and then this becomes 4 then
this becomes 3 and now the numbers are
easy to deal with 3 times 9 is 27 is
equal to 4x divide both sides by 4 you
get X is equal to 27 over 4 27 over 4
and 4 goes into 27 what is that that is
equal to 6 and 6 and 3/4 6 and 3/4 and
all of their numbers are in decimals so
that's six point seven five which is e
all right 4 times 6 is 24 and you have 3
left over right
the next problem problem 60 problem 60
in the figure of PQRS is a prologue
parallelogram that's fair let me draw
this looks interesting
so I have to draw a couple lines it's
one line they have another line that
looks something like that and then they
have the parallelogram let me connect
the lines looks like that and then they
tell us see this line actually keeps
going draw that in they tell us this is
P this is Q this is R and this is s and
they tell us that this is 140 degrees
they tell us that this is 2 y 2 y and
they tell us that this is X and then
they say in figure above what is Y minus
X so since we know this is a
parallelogram we know that this line is
parallel to this line and we know that
this line is parallel to that line that
actually tells us a lot of information
especially if we continue the lines over
then everything we learned in geometry
about parallel lines starts to hold so
this let me draw it in a different color
if this line in green is parallel to
this line then you can view this line
right here as a bit of a trends
versal and 140 degrees in 2y or
corresponding angles so they're actually
going to equal each other and you can
even eyeball in and think about why that
makes sense those lines are parallel so
140 degrees is equal to 2y y is equal to
70 fair enough
y is equal to 70 and now let's consider
that let me do is switch colors that
this line right here this magenta line
and this magenta line those two are
parallel and we can now view this as a
transversal right if this if this is a
transversal then the 70 degrees and this
angle are corresponding angles so
they're going to be equal so that's 70
and then this angle up here that 70
degrees that I just drew and the X angle
they're supplementary right they add up
to 180 so you have X plus 70 is equal to
180 so you get X is equal to 110 degrees
110 degrees
I don't know sorry I made a mistake I
made a mistake so this angle isn't 70 y
is equal to 70 but this angle is 2y so
this is 140 degrees all right we figured
out that this is 140 degrees so this has
to be 140 degrees and what my brain
caught that sounds like what that
doesn't look like 70 degrees 70 degrees
would be a lot narrower that looks more
like hundred forty but anyway this is
140 so this is 140 the corresponding
angle up here is also going to be 140
degrees and so did that wrong x plus 140
right X plus six hundred forty degrees
the logic still the same they're
supplementary equals 180 so X is equal
to forty degrees and they wanted to know
what they want to know what Y minus X is
so it's 30 70 minus 40 is 30 and that's
choice a see you in the next video